welcome back to new rock stars I'm Eric
Boss and this is a breakdown of the boys
spin-off gen V episode 8 the season
finale guardians of gulkan and this
video is sponsored by Squarespace the
all-in-one platform that makes launching
your own website of Breeze with the news
that genv is getting to season 2 I can't
wait to see where they go from here
because this season finale was Bonkers
let's break down this bloody episode
take a look at all the Easter eggs
details the links to the larger boys
universe and make some guesses about
what's going on in that ending and what
it could mean for next season so we open
on Dean shett lying dead on the floor
and everyone's freaking out without her
meds Kate's Powers keep growing and she
can hear everyone's Panic thoughts
they're all jumbled together and you can
distinctly hear Marie wondering why no
one helps shett Emma panicking about the
fact that they all killed someone Sam
repeating she butchered us and Jordan
just thinking that Kate is crazy the
thoughts swell to a cacophony and
there's this high-pitched ringing and
what sounds like a heartbeating and then
Kate closes her eyes and seemingly shuts
it all out why didn't you let me save
her am I going to help what did you
do she was evil
so it seems like this whole thing wasn't
a projection that Kate was making the
others see and Shetty is actually dead
her crusade to get revenge on the soups
for the death of her daughter and her
husband had the unintended consequence
of radicalizing Kate and also Sam who
definitely thinks that Shetty got what
she deserved Kate tries to rationalize
what just happened by saying that she
did this for all of them and then
ominously adds that when she's done
they'll realize that she's being a hero
she wants to free everyone in the woods
and Sam is 1,000% on board the others
not so much Jordan who switches from the
Persona to the female Persona at some
point during this exchange looks like
they are going to intervene but doesn't
ultimately you can beat me but do you
really think you can beat him remember
Jordan was the one who took on Luke
after he killed Brink but Sam is more
powerful than Luke was which is why
Brink and Shetty were trying to use
Sam's blood to amp up Luke's Powers so
Kate is probably right that Jordan can't
take on Sam in a one-on-one fight like
we've seen that dude rip guys in half it
would have been fun to see Jordan a
puppet though as he sizes them up Sam
flares his nostrils like a bull also no
is the little don't do it headshake that
Marie gives Jordan because the two are
always looking out for one another the
remaining three each want to handle this
in different ways Jordan wants to call
the campus security emergency line to
give them a heads up but Emma doesn't
want to do anything that will get Sam
caught Marie wants to stop this on their
own because she doesn't trust vot or
gulan everyone in genv has their own
idea of what a hero is and how to be one
something that will come up several
times in this episode Andre is still
with his dad in VA Tower after his
seizure last episode and the doctor
tells him what they found on the MRI
apparently every time polarity used his
powers it caused damage in his brain
that cannot be reversed it's just really
interesting to see the long-term effects
of using powers which is something that
doesn't come up much in other superhero
properties except for maybe like 2017's
Logan a movie that really just had the
mission of how Bleak can we make this
but we have seen this a couple times in
the boys gen V Universe when Kate uses
her powers it's assumed that she's
causing damage as evidenced by the
popped blood vessels in her eyes and
when butcher used temp V he developed
brain tumors there was also at Train's
heart issues because of his compound V
addiction but this is really the first
time that we have a doctor confirming
that a soup using their powers caused a
medical emergency the larger question of
whether everyone who is given compound V
at any point in their lives might have
negative physical repercussions it's
just really cool it's one that I hope
they go into further in either of these
series it goes beyond just the ethical
issues around people having powers as
Andre talks to the doctor there's
artwork on the wall one piece that kind
of looks like a hole in the center of
shattered glass another that looks like
a spiral maybe these represent Andre's
World viw shattering and it subsequent
spiraling the doctor asks Andre if he's
experienced any lightheadedness or spots
in his vision or uncontrollable ticks in
the ring or pinky figure and Andre
responds doesn't doesn't everybody get
lightheaded
sometimes can we can we focus on my dad
or I mean I just I love that his face
Twitches In This Moment later on when
he's using his powers we actually see
his ring in pinky fingers twitch there
is a ticking clock on this kid before he
ends up like his dad if he keeps using
his powers and we are already seeing the
effects Andre talks to his dad and giv
given what happened in the ambulance
last episode I'm surprised they didn't
remove all metal objects from this room
like when Magneto was imprisoned in
X-Men Andre barely gets a sentence out
before his dad launches into it go
through my
phone the contacts for Heather are in
there Heather Heather PR or wardrobe
wardrobe polarity is immediate concern
isn't his health it's getting his
superhero costume resized to fit Andre I
love that vot has two Heathers just like
it has two Ashley's both just kind of
those popular mean girl names from the '
80s movies polarity apologizes to Andre
and confirms that he did know about the
woods but he played along to protect him
he says that school is done now it's
time for Andre to step up and that he
should quote do whatever they tell you
this is similar to Victoria Newman
telling Marie that she had two paths to
get ahead play by vot's rules or keep
causing trouble and digging things up
trying to be a real hero I have to
assume that polarity doesn't know that
Andre might be in danger if he keeps
using his powers because if he does know
woof he also says this your family's
counting on you jeez man laying that
parental pressure on thick okay so a lot
of people online have been wondering how
Ryan homelander son can be the first
Natural Born soup if Andre and Maverick
translucent son exist so I want to
address that here while the shows
haven't explicitly stated this I believe
that Andre and Maverick were born as
non-powered humans to their parents
remember homelander stated that he
thought he couldn't have children but no
one ever said that no soup can have kids
like we've seen many that do Victoria
Newman Mesmer Stormfront to name a few
so I think that polarity and translucent
gave their sons compound v as babies and
they ended up having similar Powers as
their dads Because of the genetic
similarities that already existed in
their blood knowing vot the company
probably even encouraged soups to have
their kids dose with compound V because
it's good for their brand if America
sees a family of soups so no I do not
think that Andre and Maverick were born
as soups like from the moment of
conception which would mean that Ryan is
the first natural boore naturally
conceived soup unless there's one out
there that we haven't seen yet Ashley
and the Border are on campus and in
crisis mode I'm missing a farmed a table
Fest at AA and Jeff to be at this board
meeting but someone has to save this
place Ina G is a cook who hosts a Food
Network show The Barefoot Contessa and
Jeffrey is her husband who she talks
about a lot on the show to distract from
all the negative PR that the school has
been getting lately Ashley wants to send
a student straight to the seven which
currently has four open slots since the
only ones remaining are homelander the
deep and a train they discuss their
options starting with Andre who has a
headshot in a resume like actors do
although it seems like this one was put
together for him by the board his resume
says Powers magnetic telepathy GPA 3.3
which Ashley calls terrible and then IQ
120 which she thinks is surprisingly
good height 510 weight 185 lbs pedigree
son of polarity and Lila Anderson
followed by polarity is a known entity
Lila runs their brand I don't think
we've seen Lila at all yet it's a little
weird that she wasn't at the hospital
with polarity but maybe this is just one
of those celebrity marriages it's just
for show or something under stats it
says Optics rating a max bench 350 lbs
magnetic weight limit 12 tons followed
by some writing that ends with could be
higher I'm assuming that the magnetic
weight limit is how much he can move by
using his his magnetic powers 12 tons is
24,000 lb or the equivalent of a school
bus or two elephants the helicopter he
stops from crashing later on is within
that weight range although since it's
falling that would add some extra
difficulty hence why he is struggling in
that moment we see additional skills
British accent which is sort of an
inside joke because Chance Pomo the
actor who plays Andre is an American
born British actor with dual citizenship
I also love how just like real actors
sups Pat out their resumes with stupid
stuff like this He's listed as having
21.1 million Instagram followers which
isn't as many as Jenna Ortega but is
more than chance Pomo has in real life
we see sponsorship opportunities Sports
technology men's products and then risks
was friends with Golden Boy influence
unknown relationship with Father
reportedly Rocky may act out in the
short term as a way to rebel against the
brand has disappeared from events in the
past would need to be closely monitored
until he's under control and then
finally something that ends with with a
Handler until he gets his footing that
reference about him disappearing from
events goes back to episode 2 when he
bailed on his interview with Haley
Miller vot knows almost everything about
these kids down to predicting but
potential Behavior the very white board
member isn't sold on Andre his on screen
skin color test read a bit dark they
will get any libowitz to shoot him you
racist [__] Annie liab Bitz has been
criticized in the past for not knowing
how to properly photograph people of
color and specifically black women like
Simone biles and Supreme Court Justice
Kaji Brown Jackson so it's kind of funny
that that's who Ashley went with Kate
and Sam go back to the woods the first
time Sam has been back here since he
escaped Kate I haven't seen you down
here in a while Greg uh I'm Bob this
continues the ongoing bit of everyone
getting these two guards mixed up both
and Greg it's similar to a running thing
on lost with two Castaways named Scott
and Steve that everyone got confused or
kind of like in Aliens where Hicks and
Hudson were mixed up or in Harry Potter
where George and Fred often mixed up but
you know they were literal twins but
Greg was the guard that Sam killed in
episode 4 whose jumpsuit he stole and
was wearing when he and emo were both at
the drive-in so now Sam has taken out
both Greg and Bob rip to both of you but
you know not really because you did
torture children this guard recognizes
Kate from when she was down there
helping shett and Brank with Luke during
his blood transfusions it's interesting
that Shetty didn't have Kate wipe the
guard's memories but I guess they know
what they signed up for and in for a
penny and for a pound with the torturers
Sam punches through Bob's face and then
tears his eyes out and squishes them
which we do not see in puppet Vision but
horrible horrible reality I think this
indicates that Sam is becoming more okay
with committing violent acts since I
believe he switched a puppet Vision to
protect himself anytime he was doing
something terrible that he couldn't
properly process Kate orders the next
guard to unlock the cells and this whole
scene is reminiscent of season 2 of the
boys when all the suit patients in Sage
Grove psychiatric facility were all let
out of their cells and run them up we
see this one patient Crouch down in the
shadows with glowing eyes which looks
terrifying it reminds me of the first
time we see the creatures in The Descent
also the first time we see Gollum in
Fellowship of the Ring when he was just
this shadowy silhouette crouching down
over the ring with glowing eyes we also
see this soup with Nightcrawler esque
teleportation Powers disappearing and
then reappearing in his cell Kate
releases this very sweaty soup when's
the last time you saw
sunlight is Gangam Style still a thing
yes genam style was released in 2012 and
this guy looks about 20 years old so he
would have been around 9 years old when
he was locked up also the music video
for genam style currently has 4.9
billion views which is insane now at
first I thought maybe the soup was so
sweaty because he was infected with the
virus but later on we see that he is the
ability to melt things with his hands
still I have to wonder if any of them
who came into contact with Andy when he
was infected might have the virus at
that point it was still spread by
contact with bodily fluids and it would
be interesting to see this plot carry on
into season 2 if there's an escaped
ected soup out there walking around on
his way out Sam stops by his old cell
and hallucinates Luke who tries to talk
him out of what he's doing it's
interesting that Luke is in a puppet
when he sees him makes me wonder if this
is something more than just his usual
episodes like maybe because of the
repeated blood transfusions and the
experiments part of Luke's Consciousness
actually exists in Sam's brain now it
could explain why Luke kept having
visions of young Sam Kate gives her Army
of escapees a rallying speech you are
superior to them and it's time we showed
it this is similar to stuff Stormfront
and homelander have said in the past and
it's quite the turn for Kate up until
now she rationalized everything she was
doing like wiping Luke's memory making
the others forget as being for her
friends to keep them safe but now she
seems to genuinely think that all
non-powered people deserve to be wiped
out because of the actions of a select
few Kate tells the guard to eat his own
hands and somehow the fact that he does
it with his gloves still on makes it
worse Rufus tries unsuccessfully to film
himself lip syncing to Desperado by
Rihanna there were a few different Tik
Tok Trends using song for a while the
sweaty guy from the woods interrupts him
to ask if he's a soup and ruus answers
in his usual dickish way no [__] [__]
then sweaty asks this woman the same
thing and she's very polite so naturally
she's the one he kills the poor woman
says she's an Adjunct professor she's
not even fulltime but she gets her face
melted despite not having tenure the
students immediately take out their
phones to live stream what's happening
because that's how Jen Z processes
everything God used social media adviser
Jeff walks in front of this mural which
looks very much like the mishmash of all
the San Diego ComiCon posters ever then
he reveals that he's a mole for vot I
assume put on campus keep an eye on
things and report back as one of the
escaped soups rushes at him he uses a
sonar weapon device to incapacitate her
is similar to the ones that the guards
in the woods used but includes a dial to
really control the frequency the one we
saw the guard use previously just had an
onoff button he puts a silver disc in
her mouth and cranks the device making
her head explode and then he phones
Ashley to to tell her his cover is blown
and their rehab might be unlocked before
we can get any more out Kate pushes him
and forces him to use a disc to pop his
own head while live streaming it a
campus security guard users are walking
to notify everyone of the escaped meth
heads which is how they referred to Sam
in episode one when he' escaped the
woods so I'm guessing that methhead is
code for crazy pissed off soups who want
us all dead and can rip out our spines
big holiday feasts aren't just about
what's on the table they're about the
whole experience the company the
decorations the vibe for lack of a
better word running an online business
is similar offering a quality product
isn't enough you want to make sure
things are just right and for that
there's squar space SP Squarespace is an
all-in-one platform that provides you
with everything you need to do whatever
you need with your website Squarespace
has templates and designs for pretty
much everything so even if you're making
your very first website using
Squarespace makes it super easy to
customize your look update content and
add features to fit your unique needs
for instance Squarespace makes it easy
to sell merch you can design your
products then save time and money by
letting Squarespace handle production
inventory and shipping and if you're
selling any other kind of physical Goods
digital Goods or even a service
Squarespace makes it easy to build your
storefront and grow your business to
check it out for yourself head to
squarespace.com for a free trial and
when you're ready to launch go to
squarespace.com neww rockstars to save
10% off your first purchase of a website
or domain in Adam bork's acting class A
student does a truly awful monologue
from dawn of the 7 pandering to bour who
wrote and directed the film if this is
going to be the dawn of the
seven we have to first get through dusk
Bor loves it his ego sufficiently
stroked and he even gives the student a
stand Innovation slow clap Works wearing
a finny Pizza hat and that is a pizza
chain in New York City his class lecture
is interrupted by Sam's entrance okay
remember when I talk about stage
presence everybody that is not it yeah
honestly I choke this guy out too just
for a badmouthing National Treasure Josh
hartnet go rewatch his episodes of Drunk
History and tell me that man has no
stage presence he blew me away in
Oppenheimer that guy's Got Talent Emma
stops Sam from killing Bor and then we
get one of the most heartbreaking scenes
of the Season Sam is Big mad at everyone
and everything recalling his time in the
woods being tortured and he's taking it
out on Emma even as she reminds him that
she risked everything for him Emma you
would do anything for everyone to like
you you're not a hero no you don't mean
I feel so bad for Emma in this moment
and honestly while I understand that Sam
is dealing with a lot I'm not sure I buy
how abrupt his turn is about his
feelings for Emma especially since it
was only a couple episodes ago that he
told her this I'm going to make you
remember remember
what that you're a hero yeah I still
feel like there might be something more
going on here with his about face like
either he's being controlled or made to
feel abused or something but maybe this
is just wishful thinking because I want
Emma to be treated better by the guy she
just made sweet puppet love too as Emma
cries we get this cool effect shot where
she's shrinking and the background is
blurred and then we see her standing
there in giant t-shirt and shoes so this
must be a new element to her powers like
a sort of leveling up because obviously
she's had to have cried before in her
life but she's surprised that this made
her shrink which means that this is the
first time it happened so maybe the
power isn't it's feeling a deeper depth
of Despair where you no longer want to
exist anymore I just love that this
whole scene start to finish of Sam and
Emma's raw feelings Works in direct
justos to the fake drama and emotion of
the crappy acting scene that just came
before it Sam has another conversation
with imaginary Luke who acts like the
angel on Sam's shoulder to Kate's devil
right now be a hero stop Kate but he
chooses instead to let Kate push him to
feel nothing and continues on with his
Rampage around campus as the Rogue Subs
take out pretty much anyone who doesn't
have power as Marie makes it to shed's
office to hit the panic button which was
actually visible in episode 7 when Maria
and Jordan were hiding under the desk
and we finally get our code read the
dorm room bars slam shut locking
everyone in and there's another Sonic
weapon blast deployed remember soups
have better hearing than non-powered
people so they use Sonic whistle to
subdue them Bor pounds on the door of
the room where Ashley and the board
members are we saw these two hooking up
in the bathroom at the dawn of the S
Premiere at season 3 of the boys so this
has happened at least twice another soup
with Banshee like Powers shouts and
takes out the Sonic whistle and Ashley
tells Ashley to to find homelander so
this confirms that despite being
potentially put on trial for lasering
her due to death homelander is still
employed by vot and will still do what
they ask Ashley calls Marie and says
that if she takes down the Rogue soups
it means automatic entry to the seven an
offer that the board is making to
everyone and Ashley switches from her
panicked voice to her CEO voice Marie
Maro Ashley Barrett vot we are
considering you for the seven
congratulations we're so excited she
also sweetens the deal by saying she
will get her in a meeting with her
sister and Marie's heroism path in her V
controlled path are actually in
alignment I'm guessing that Marie's
sister is going to play a bigger role in
season 2 I'm interested to see where she
ended up after the parents death and if
she has powers as well it was never
mentioned whether both of them were
injected with compound V's baby or just
Marie all the phones cut out and the
Wi-Fi goes down causing one to be
influencers Justine and Harper to freak
out even more than when the code red
locked them in the room Kate touches a
soup who can fly and makes him take down
the helicopter that's there to rescue
Ashley in the board and Andre chooses to
use his powers even though he knows it
can make his brain mush he chooses to be
a hero and is right there with him
Guardians gulin we do this together am I
right let's go Andre was one of the
original guardians of gulin but he
shered his responsibilities just like
the board's resume said about him he
acted out in the short term as a way to
rebel against a polarity brand but now
he's taking what his father told him
seriously and he's stepping up the
medication that Shetty was giving Kate
has worn off allowing her to level up
her powers but all that pushing is still
taking a toll both her eyes are almost
completely red because of the burst
blood vessels making her look
particularly villain I wonder if the
meds were helping Kate in some way even
though they were dampening her powers
maybe they were also protecting her from
doing too much physical damage to
herself at once even though Marie tells
Kate that she has no intention of
killing her like vot once Kate still
pushes Maverick to stop her and he takes
off his hat and glasses to go fullon
invisible Andre runs after Kate with
these weird bounding leaps and I guess
his superpower is not to look cool
during a Chase Marie States behind to
fight Maverick which is hard because as
a tagline of his dad's movie says you
can't kill what you can't see in the
boys Butcher and huy had to fight
translucent while he was invisible and
the only way butcher was able to win was
because he spit his own blood on
translucent and was able to see where he
was here we get a variation on that
Marie has been learning and honing her
powers all season and now she uses what
Newman taught her to First hear
Maverick's heart pumping and the blood
slashing around and then see where he is
she knocks him out with a handy piece of
wreckage and he materializes both he and
his dad were defeated by Blood albeit in
different ways we see a slightly younger
Maverick on the boys during his dad's
funeral but this doesn't look like the
same Act he's clearly not dead just
inconscious and I'm sure his girlfriend
the alaka soup Sloan will be happy to
nurse him back to health later also
again what is Sloan's deal writers you
better have more Sloan in season two
Jordan saves Ashley and the board from a
soup really they should be considering
all of our regulars for the seven right
now because they owe them Andre appeals
to Kate to stop this the way he did when
they were trapped in her mind but notice
how he keeps his distance he doesn't
trust her not to use her powers on him
Kate seems to give in and reaches out to
take his hand but he doesn't fight he's
not sure if she's being sincere and
honestly neither am I at this point I
think she's gone too far to stop now and
if he'd taken her hand she'd have pushed
him to join her Crusade he gets a hard
body check from Sam who then does a
stereotypical superhero jump and ground
punch Landing the fact that Kate doesn't
do anything as Sam whales on Andre makes
me think he was right not to trust her
Andre uses his powers to pull a dead
guard's shock stick toward him and this
is where you can see his fingers
twitching ominously he shocks Sam and
they both collapse Marie tells Kate that
she originally wanted to be a hero so
that her sister could be proud of her
but now she just wants to be a good
person and Kate says that she's not a
person to them just a product and again
I know she's on a murderous Rampage to
kill a bunch of people but she's not
wrong vot created soups monitors them
and controls what they do because that's
what's important to their bottom line
also don't think too hard about how this
is an anti- capitalist anti-a
Corporation show that's a product of
Amazon some Rogue soups go after Jordan
so of course Marie swoops in for the
rescue again proving that in the class
superlatives Department she'd get most
improved she uses her power to give this
one ey laser soup a heart attack Jordan
takes out the sweaty soup and as a
teleporting soup goes after the board of
the helicopter we get this moment one of
my favorites from the entire Series this
moment is so great that Bor says he's
putting in his next movie and I hope we
get to see that movie Down the Line
Marie tells Jordan see we're good
together echoing what Andre just told
Kate moments before Kate whenever either
one of us does something on our own she
gets screwed up big time but I know we
do some amazing [__] together yeah even
though they have incredible Powers
really they're still just teenagers
trying to figure this all out and make a
connection to people they love love as
Jordan walks Marie Kate reaches out for
them and Marie inadvertently makes her
arm explode the way she did ruus his
penis as Kate screams we hear sonic boom
and we get the Cameo I suspect it was
coming homelander he sets down right in
front of a statue his superhero music
playing triumphantly before distorting
and petering out indicating that there's
may be something wrong with this
[Music]
Rescue all Chaos on campus comes to stop
like he's their disapproving father
catching them in the middle of a rager
and just like a dad who's not mad had
just disappointed he does a signature
finger waggle we've seen him do this
before many times he has a very emotive
finger if Marie thought that he was
there to rescue her and the others
trying to protect the school from the
Rogue soups though she was sorely
mistaken he in episode seven when Jordan
was causing a diversion and Marie could
talk to Newman Harper filmed Jordan
punching Justine and said Jordan Lee
attacking her own kind so obviously it's
a big deal to some soups when one uses
Powers against other powered people
homelander calls for everyone to stay
back as Marie looks on confused and then
he blasts her with his laser eyes and
everything goes black then there's a
news broadcast from Cameron Coleman
painting Emma Marie and Andre and Jordan
as the instigators of the rampage that
killed 12 people and painting Kate and
Sam as the protectors the new Guardians
Of gulkan homelander Watches This creepy
smile plane on his face knowing Amy's
probably pissed that he wasn't given
sole credit for saving the day but it's
also possible that he's the one who
wanted it this way like he wants to look
like the leader of a movement we've seen
him in the past be very particular about
who is led into the seven he's
definitely on brand for him and vot to
prefer to two white kids to the diverse
group with powers that as Brink put it
back in episode one don't play well in
the rustbell states Marie wakes up in
hospital bed in this white room with
Jordan Emma and Andre Andre tells Marie
that she took a blast like a champ and
anyone else would be in the ground but
also I've got to assume that homelander
didn't hit her with the full blast power
and that Ashley or the board made it
clear that he shouldn't kill any of them
or he's keeping them alive for some
other purpose or maybe Marie's just
really powerful Marie realized this room
has no doors but we do see a hatch on
the ceiling and we get an appropriate
Charlie from Lost
line
where are we and we own on the muffs
Kids In America playing over the credits
but there's one surprise came in the
post credit scene Billy butcher in the
woods now cleared out and abandoned
confirming my suspicion last episode
that he was the one that Grace mallerie
was talking to on the phone so I think
in season two we'll see vot taking full
control of gulan since we know how much
corporations love a Rebrand and claiming
that what happened was an isolated
incident but everything is safe now
they'll use the school as a suit
pipeline into their brands and movies
and commercials and they'll cut a deal
with Marie and Jordan Andre and Emma
that if they play ball and do what they
say they'll shift the narrative in their
favor and each of them will once again
be faced with a question of whether they
want to be a hero or a vot puppet I do
find it interesting that the room
holding the genv crew right now has the
same horizontal lines toward the top of
the room that we saw in the Cell at vot
Tower that held mave it's probably some
bottom level bunker of the tower
designed to hold dangerous soups I want
to know from you what did you think of
genv how did Marie survive that blast
and like Marie asked where are they let
us know your theories in the comments
subscribe to new rock stars the Deep
dive in the break room support us byr
it's merch at nerd r. shop big thanks to
Gina apilo and Brandon barck for the
help writing this breakdown follow me at
eaos follow new rockstars subscribe to
new rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love thanks for watching
[Music]
bye